[Music]
I'm so happy to talk to you thank you
for coming out here absolutely you are
an unbelievable badass but you also have
this really captivating compelling story
emotional story and I look forward to
digging into it with you yeah me too
yeah but before we even do that
you just came from Alaska right you did
the dinner odd I did mushing yeah they
have a human-powered event so yeah I did
350 miles Iditarod Trail on a snow bike
a fat bike
did you do that as part of an organized
race or what was the situation it is
it's the Iditarod Trail Invitational has
been going on about seven this was 18th
year and you can bike ski run it and
just human powers however I want to do
it but on the same trail is the dog as
the historic dogsled race dogs start
about a week after so it's right how
long did that take you I was almost four
days on the trail to cover 350 miles so
it's it's slow going and it's full
survival mode where you just carry all
your gear all your gear on the bike I
think my bike weighed 65 pounds well
sleeping bag stove navigation equipment
batteries lighting you know basically
everything to survive in the Alaskan
wilderness so that was that was tops of
you know in all of my years probably one
of the scariest most intimidating most
committing expeditions I've ever done
because of the elements because it was
survival and honestly you know if you're
tired and you have to stop
you know you freeze it's minus 25 and
night there so it was one of the few
times where I've really feared for my
safety mm-hmm which is why it took me
this long to actually do that event I've
been an intrigued by it for a long time
but cold is is one of my sort of primal
fears you've been cold so when it yeah
it took me a while to get to Alaska and
the winter in the wilderness
I had kala no Brady in here the other
day who just traversed Antarctica and
one of the interesting things that he
was sharing about that was that
when he's pulling this 375 pound sled
behind him the most important thing is
to make sure that you're not over
exerting yourself because the minute you
start sweating that's death so is that a
similar thing that you had to deal with
absolutely and I reached out to Colin
and some explorers and some people I
knew who had spent time in those
elements to just try to educate myself
and ask about equipment and safety and
yeah absolutely
sweating is is death you know in
sub-zero temperatures and so there's
this constant management of what you're
wearing what you're taking even if your
hands are sweating my hands are sweating
thinking about it right now but yeah
simple things like eating drinking
taking care of your skin taking care of
your body those become paramount and the
the physical exertion is almost the last
part of the equation right was there a
moment where you were really in danger
or did you manage it all well I I was
super I had this heightened focus
because I was really scared about
getting wet you're crossing open water
all the time you're on ice that's
cracking underneath you your foot falls
in you know and gets wet that is a done
yeah that is a nice shot phones or were
you able to communicate with anybody if
you got into a problem
I had a Garmin inReach satellite
tracking device that I could send text
messages out and yeah my husband was
aware of what I where I was you know I
had the race directors number but even
so it's gonna be hours or days so
somebody gets to you but I did have I
did have that as a you know Garmin
device as a safety backup because yeah I
I don't do sports to risk my life it's
not my motivating factor and so I did
try to have all these kind of bailout
plans but um yeah moments of fear and
terror and being worried for myself
absolutely every night when the Sun went
down the temperature plummets and I went
to pretty dark physically an emotionally
dark place just because it's Alaska in
the winter and the dark
and it's gonna be -20 and if you make
one mistake it can be very costly and
probably the scariest night was the last
night I was out I had to sleep out in
the field and I had planned to there are
little small huts every 50 to 80 miles
or so and my plan was never to have to
sleep outside and really use my
equipment but I was in a point where I
was too far between and stumbling and
falling over and you know would sleep
deprivation and so I did sort of have to
grapple back and forth I don't want to
sleep outside
I have to sleep outside and spend a
couple hours doing that and I did sleep
out and you know in the snow - sub-zero
temperatures and you know put tree
branches down as a like full serve I'll
put tree wrenches down as a insulator
from the ground and my sleeping pad and
put all my clothes on and got inside the
sleeping bag and and passed right out
and fell asleep and got some great rest
but I think that was a breakthrough for
me to learn to trust the equipment and
and trust that you know it was gonna
work and I could use it appropriately so
I'll be back I'm already planning oh
really
yeah of course well I can do it better
it was a little messy I finished I was
the first woman I was 10th overall but
you know I I waste
I was inefficient so now I want to go
back with some efficiency and confidence
and it probably was other than Idaho
where I live the most beautiful place
I've ever been on earth Wow when you say
10th overall is that across all
different disciplines like people yeah
people there I think 40 49 or 50 started
and in the bike in sort of my division
20 finished 14 got evacuated for
frostbite on the first night lots of
people drop out and then you have to if
you drop out at a certain certain spots
where you basically have to pay a bunch
of money and hire a bush plane to come
in and get you so so site people are
riding bikes they're cross-country
skiing are people just doing it by foot
so do it on foot and they're they're
towing a sled you know behind them
it sort of tends to be that the cyclists
tend to finish first and you know as far
as a human-powered and then ski and foot
are the sort of the next right the next
fastest people but you know it takes a
while you know if you're moving on the
bikes five miles an hour average is a
really fast speed for a snow bike so you
take the mileage and you you have to
totally change your sort of I mean Road
Cycling anything else where 15 20 miles
an hour's yeah that all gets thrown out
the window your perspective on what it
is to go fast well and then you're like
I only have ten miles for the next
checkpoint but that may be four hours
right Wow
and what did you do about hydration and
nutrition like wouldn't your water
bottles just free would you have to stop
and and you know melt snow for water or
how did that work yeah the food and the
water and that's the that's where I feel
like I failed myself I didn't do very
well with it and I had talked to Colin
and all those other people about what
kind of foods don't freeze out there and
of course no gels no you know anything
like that and the way it is you carry
your first you start with a bunch of
food and then there were two food drops
that we had sent five pounds each that
you that were air dropped into certain
spots along the course and in there you
could have food batteries hand warmers
basically just consumable things so I
had pre-made all these stuff like little
peanut butter balls and date balls and
cut everything up really small lots of
cheese and fats and high density foods
and basically I hated all of it I didn't
I didn't want to eat it
I couldn't digest it you know it's all
frozen you can't take a bite out of
something people whose fillings cuz you
can't so everything was cut bite-sized
but food and water was a real problem
for me so Colin had told me you need to
eat four to five thousand calories a day
like in the Arctic that's what you have
to do and I wasn't I was probably
getting in 1,500 oh and so I'm eating
myself basically you know I'm you know
burning my own fat and the energy levels
were really low because I didn't do well
with food
drink and then Camelback is worn
underneath your clothes all you know the
hoses in your armpit and so even to take
one drink you unzip 17 layers pull your
face masks down and so I got lazy and it
was just like I don't feel like drinking
anything
hmm and so I would change that and I
would carry I did have a thermos and
that was kind of my saving grace where I
get hot water and then that was easiest
to drink but you have to stop to eat and
drink it's not like on a bicycle where
you can grab something out of your
Jersey and and stuff it in your face and
you're alone in the whole time right the
solitude of that yeah and you know
there's I do a lot of training alone and
it is a bit of my meditation my therapy
I don't I don't mind being alone but
this was truly there like wow I am
really out there I mean I know I was
howling at the moon
literally what did you have friends
predatory run it run ins with predatory
wildlife I saw lots of evidence of it
wolf Prince as big as you know a saucer
along the bike tracks and tons of
evidence
I saw probably 25 moose I don't know
what the plural of moose you don't know
the moose and you know I saw him and
there on the trail and they were walking
away and moose can be really dangerous
so yeah wolf moose but I wasn't scared
of the animals as much as I was I didn't
feel that kind of fear or the fear of
being alone it was more the fear of the
elements and yeah you know if your bike
breaks or something happens you really
do have to be super self-sufficient
so that was my biggest fear and when you
finish then the traditional Iditarod is
getting ready to go right yeah exactly
you got to see them off we did see them
off and I was really intrigued by um I
was pretty intrigued by the dog-human
relationship and I could read about that
on Instagram yeah I went and visited
Martin Buser is one of the most famous
Alaskan dog Sutter he's just completed
I think his 38th Iditarod how long have
we been going on 50 about 50 years
something Wow you know and he's done
almost every one of them I mean that
kind of longevity is pretty amazing so I
actually went to his kennel hasn't
visited and met the dogs and I'm reading
his book now because it's just such an
interesting historic one the his history
of that trail is intriguing to me but
also the relationship between an animal
and a human as athletes is fascinating
yeah it's like symbiotic thing right I
mean you have dogs I have dogs when I
put on my running shoes or the dogs my
bike they are just jumping out of their
skin and they want to run and it's my
trail runs are elevated by their joy and
you know it's just seeing a being that
just is like I want to run like I don't
always feel that way when I head out for
a run I don't know if you do there's
like I'm trying to be good to go
they're like up in the morning happy
good to go from zero to 60 no warm-up
needed mm-hmm it's it's kind of a cool
energy so when I remand out it's like
you know what would diesel do one of my
dogs and there's that race takes off and
there's people that are still finishing
your race right so they're passing each
other yeah so I did the short version of
the Iditarod Trail so I basically did
you know the 350 mile version the whole
trails start to finish and this is what
the dogsled to do is a thousand miles
and so I think only four riders or have
completed so far the thousand this year
they they've have finished and yeah they
get caught by the dogsled teams if
you're doing a longer course and so then
you're all intermixed together and
there's a lot of respect from what I
understand between the mushers you know
seeing someone human-powered out there
they're just like wow you do that
without dogs a lot of respect yeah yeah
that's interesting
wow what a cool and now a charm
California warp did you when did you get
back I got back yeah recently like 11 or
12 days ago so I'm still kind of I think
my temperature regulation is a little
bit off waking up with like now
sweats and I don't know if that ever
happens you after a really big event I
think my body is still kind of cleansing
but I'm not surprised that you're like
okay I'm going back here's what I'm
gonna change here's what I'm gonna do
better you know I'm surprised I'm
surprised myself because of the cold but
I have the confidence now that that the
gear works and I have the mentality for
it and so yeah I can do it better I
don't doubt that you have the mentality
for it I want to you know really get
into the Ho Chi Minh Trail story but I
think the best way to do that is really
to just tell your story from the
beginning
you know growing up in a suburb outside
of Chicago and what that was like and
the relationship that you you know had
and didn't have with your dad that kind
of informs you know this adventure that
you know you're perhaps best known for
absolutely yeah Midwestern kid well my
dad was in the Air Force he was a
navigator and f4 phantom but he was shot
down when I was just three so mom sis
and I grew up in suburbs of Chicago you
know three girls and at that time you
know mom is a single parent that wasn't
really as common as it is now and so she
was at work all day and my sister and I
were you know really kind of left to
fend for ourselves you know no fault of
my mom she had to work but we really did
develop an independence and she's your
sister older or younger
she's a couple years older she's in the
Air Force now she's a general now Wow
yeah general banister Isis two badass
women your mom did something right I
think a lot of what she did absolutely
and I think a lot of my sister our paths
are I think because of my mom seeing
this example of really hard-working
independent you know working in computer
programming in immense feel there was
never like oh girls don't do that or it
was just this example of you work super
hard and go do what you want to do and I
took a Sportster out you know my sister
took
you know the military and more
intellectual route in some ways but I
still do feel like we picked up the same
skill base from my mom just by her
leading for example through example but
you're you're very much you're your
father's daughter you know you you
really seem to embody a lot of the
characteristics that kind of defined his
character being this adventurer and this
explorer well thanks for saying that I
didn't know that until recently and it
has brought up an interesting question
of nature versus nurture and you know is
your upbringing what shapes you or or
you know your genes and what's in your
DNA and and I do believe it's a
combination of both and my sister and I
had the impact of my mother being there
day to day to learn those traits from
her
I didn't realize and my sister as well
she's followed in my dad's footsteps in
the military and service and she and I
obviously both inherited a big piece of
him I inherited the wandering you know
living out of your car guy and she
inherited the this service and and
dedication of the Air Force and I didn't
realize that until until I did ride the
Ho Chi Minh Trail and blood road and you
know well into my 40s decided you know
my adventure lifestyle had finally
brought me to go search for something a
lot bigger than a podium mm-hmm well
we're gonna work our way but it begins
you know on a track in in Illinois right
you started out like as a runner yeah I
found I found running you know it's
really interesting it you know you have
kids and high school and junior high for
girls is a tough time yeah I mean it's
nine-year-old daughter yes anyone you're
trying to figure out what do you wear to
school how do you fit in you know who
are my people and you know I was in the
band it was kind of band geek and some
of that stuff but I found I found
athletics and I really do feel like it
was and continues to be a savior for me
I had body image issues as a young girl
and you know my neighborhood is kind of
funny story my neighbor who was in the
cross
country team she's like well you know if
you joined the cross-country team and I
didn't know what it was
you get a free tracksuit it's like those
Cotton's matching you know hoodie
sweatpants and yeah pop they're pretty
cool they're coming back around now so
you get a free sweat suit and you'll
never get fat and is a you know junior
high school girl going into high school
and like oh that sounds pretty good
and motivation that was the motivation
tracksuit mmm-hmm stay skinny yeah and
it's not the wrong not the right
motivation but it definitely put me in a
place to find a community and friends
and confidence and you know work ethic
and all these things that I've carried
with me my whole entire life yeah did
you distinguish yourself as an athlete
at that age yeah I was ended up being
Allstate and you know had had success in
the cross-country running team and it
was great I loved it it was kind of what
I live for
and the sense of freedom and running
around in the woods that was fed every
part of me that that is still alive and
well was there a conscious sense that
this is what you wanted your life to be
about at that early age it was the first
thing in my life that I found I belonged
to and that it it was fun it was super
hard
there was the reward of you know working
in a team and winning something and
having a metal put around your neck and
probably even bigger than that was the
exploration and the cross-country trails
you know it's different than a track
right so you go to a cross-country meet
and every meet is in a different place a
different Park that you haven't run
around in and I think that's a really
primal need for me is to explore and so
yeah there was a sense that I will
always do this and and college sort of
put the stopper on that because I had a
coach he was a real [ __ ] and just
didn't it didn't work no so I quit and
you know that was the first of many
times where I felt lost in my life but
then you know found cycling at that time
road cycling and and eventually rock
climbing you know it's led to
multiple sports right well you're you're
best known for your pursuits on a
mountain bike but what's crazy about you
is that you've distinguished yourself in
all manner of sports from you know
adventure racing whitewater rafting
cross country skiing like you you pretty
much do it all but it kind of began with
you deciding that you are gonna go into
this adventure world right like what was
first like how did this whole adventure
begin
and you're you're right there is a
common thread of all these sports that
feed the same kind of need in me instead
of just sticking to one support but
where it all began
I I believe was I mean Chicago I was
working at a health club
I had a marketing degree in Kinesiology
and was like I'm gonna work in sports
fitness or something that seemed like a
logical transition and they had an
indoor rock climbing wall and the guy
down at the wall was kind of cute and
the wall looks sort of intriguing so I
went and I learned to rock climb and
that was really the beginning of me
feeling like I needed to leave the
Midwest and I needed to climb up rocks
and right and so climbing really was the
outdoor that my invitation to the
outdoors and understanding like the dirt
bag lifestyle I lived in my car I
stopped shaving my armpits you know I
became a super bag for a while this epic
Bronco I don't have it anymore those
things cruise around Malibu there you
know like they get they get renovated
and sell for ridiculous amounts of money
that's my only regret in life is selling
the Bronco but we gotta let it go well
if that's your only regret yes I'm very
good so my car in your early 20s and
just head west in the Bronco I didn't
have the Bronco at the time I headed
west and an acura integra
was where I left Chicago it's okay that
you don't have that one any that recall
and slept and looked out of it and you
know went to see somebody went all these
places and I landed a climbing job in
California where I you know got a job at
adventure 16 which I think it's around
anymore
no it is oh yeah there's a cut there's
two of them yeah Costa Mesa I worked at
a 16 and you know taught and taught rock
climbing at Joshua Tree and that was
really you know that was really life
changing for me to just sleep out in the
desert and and and have quote-unquote a
job doing that and then I helped found
recreation which is our climbing gyms
there's one in Costa Mesa one in Santa
Monica and so I was part owner and
founder of of those climbing gyms in the
late 90s and so that was okay here I'm
using my business degree I'm managing
and running gyms and it's like an
outdoor sort of sport right so that is
the dream job there there probably
weren't that many women in this world at
that time right no so what was that like
being part of that culture I've never
considered you know it's really only
I've never considered a from my
upgrading men or women don't do this job
I mean you can definitely look around
the room go there that many women
climbing instead of me sort of being
like you know well that sucks it would
be well let's invite some more in and so
that has tended to be my mentality was
cycling oh this is your whole thing now
right
the inclusivity and and trying to you
know Rodney's broaden the doors you make
those doors swing wide open for more
women to get involved it's pretty great
I mean you see it now you go to a
climbing gym and there's tons of kids
and girls and everybody's climbing and
riding bikes and having fun and but yeah
at the time there weren't a lot of women
doing it and you know I didn't really
think about that rich I wasn't like oh
I'm a female climber I'm a female this
I'm just you're just doing doing right
yeah yeah well this is the year of free
solo so you know climbing is on the
cultural roadmap in a way that never has
been before like the awareness of it
it's just exploded because of chai and
Jimmy and Alex and Tommy and that whole
community which is really cool to see
people you know at the supermarket tucky
yeah El Cap yeah and stuff like that but
I think the film that really paints the
picture more adeptly in terms of the
culture
was for me was Valley uprising where you
really got a sense of like what this
community is like and how it kind of
percolated up and has developed over the
years so when you know when I see that
and you're sharing with me about you
know living in your car and this dirtbag
lifestyle I mean that's what I'm
envisioning kind of like this rogue pack
of people that just kind of go where you
know the season blows them and where the
you know where the next wall is it's a
pretty special community if you think
about I mean one you're you're you're
connected by people in place and you go
to a place like Joshua Tree or you're
cemani and even if you just stepped out
of your car and you're the average
tourist you can't help but be moved by
the nature of those places and yeah the
dirtbike climbers are now they're
cyclists doing it as well by packing
it's people who have this need to be in
that place whether you live in a city or
you get to live in you know Idaho or in
the mountains where you live of
California there is a healing factor in
nature and people know that it's just
you know people living out of their car
or committing to that lifestyle they've
just made a bigger commitment that they
need that in their life just like
somebody needs to go to church yeah well
there's something primal you know in our
human makeup and our in our base DNA
that I think yearns for that that we've
moved too far away from we have you know
I mean it's why I think if everyone
wrote a bike I went running or did
something outside for five minutes a day
our world would be a better place it's
why people put plants inside their house
you know as a grasp to have part of that
nature therapy so yeah lucky for us we
can do it you know as much as we do and
I think we can all embrace more of that
in our lives i mean i think the the
discussion the conversation ends up
being around like these crazy feats
whether it's you know some of the things
that you've done or alex free soloing or
the slack liners and you know wingsuit
people and it's about chasing this
thrill but that's not really what it's
about I think it's about what you just
mentioned which is just living more in
alignment with nature and being
connected in a very
tactile way to you know this world that
supports us that's spinning around in
space I don't know too many extreme
athletes and I know a lot of all those
people that you've mentioned they're all
friends and I'm sure yeah it's a small
community it's a small dedicated
community but I don't know really anyone
I mean Alex even he accepts the risk for
what he's doing but none of us go in
with the intention of wanting to yeah
there's a sense that there are
everyone's an adrenaline junkie and I
don't think that's fair or accurate
no maybe endorphin junkie it might be or
I mean for me I didn't choose to go to
Alaska and try to survive sub-zero
temperatures just because I wanted to
risk frostbite and see what would happen
it was that I really wanted to
experience Iditarod Trail in Alaska and
to to howl at the moon with the wolves
and to be so deep into you know the last
frontier and wilderness
but your Y is bigger than that overall
do you know your Y a little bit yeah but
you're the one hot to you I know I am
I'm working on it and it isn't really
until I mean your TED talk was about
your Y it was and I was just gonna say
it wasn't until 46 really when I rode
the Ho Chi Minh Trail that that you know
I've been an explorer all my life but
that was the first time that I started
to explore inside instead of outside and
that that trail riding that trail really
did make me instead of running and
looking for a finish line and and
grabbing the next adventure it it made
me slow down and and stop and look
inside for a minute and that was really
hard for more than a minute right but
that was a big transition for me to
understand why I am doing this and you
know people asked all the time you know
why do you torture yourself or you know
it seems painful and awful and what are
you doing and yeah I hope Minh Trail and
the subsequent four years that have
followed in that journey of have helped
me understand and that's why I went back
to Alaska to is
because I can finally articulate what I
stand for and what I'm doing and and the
why but it's still that kid in Downers
Grove Illinois who wanted to dig around
in the dirt in the backyard the the
impetus is the exploration but now it's
a lot more awareness of the internal
exploration instead of just the physical
and and I think also and what I get out
of you know your journey is this
discovery of how you can take these
adventures and these experiences that
you've had and and translate them tell
stories around them in a way that can be
of service to other people whether it's
opening that door for more women to get
involved or you know really to be of
service to the people of Southeast Asia
you know which we're gonna get into I
think it's an amazing transition and
hopefully all humans get there you know
it's part of the aging process perhaps
when we realize that that the more you
give the more you get back and that it
really just isn't about us anymore or
yourself anymore and that has been a
really exciting revelation for me then
yeah I'm still super competitive
I was afraid when I got back from the Ho
Chi Minh Trail that the competitive
nature and spirit was gone and what am I
gonna do now and and what does this all
mean and that really is where I I spent
probably a couple years and what you
might call depression I'm trying to
evaluate well Who am I now and what does
this all stand for and and is the
athlete competitor and me gone and if
she is what's next well I think how you
define competitive an athlete evolves
right so now my sense is that what can
drive you is a more sustainable fuel
which is to continue to do what you do
but do it in a way that really does
provide service to other people you know
and that's like a sustainable fuel
source that you can continue to rely
upon as opposed to I'm going to chase
another podium
ultimately it's like who cares anymore
right yeah you know 52 it's like does
anyone really you know do another race
like you've done every race you've
dominated you know all the most you know
crazy competitive mountain bike races
and adventure races out there you don't
have anything to prove to anybody so
what will continue to propel you and
it's only by finding like purpose and
meaning in in these adventures that can
you know be a way for other people to
clean insights about their own lives
it's powerful it's I mean it's what this
podcast is about is sharing and I think
blood road showed me the power of
sharing a story because I'm pretty
introverted you know I go on long rides
and runs behind myself and I mean and
it's like a selfish thing right you're
like how long can I do this is this
really what I should be doing which I'm
sure questions you've you know wrestled
with their questions I ask all the time
I mean I don't want people to think race
is a four-letter word because I do feel
like events organize events like that
really help help somebody push
themselves beyond what you would do
alone and absolutely I you know would
push myself harder in an event like I
did a rod and it's organized its laid
out for me even though it's super remote
and so I'll probably race my whole life
even though people who ask when are you
gonna stop racing or adventure or
whatever you want to call it and you're
a race director you have your own races
I do that we're gonna try to convert you
to the wonderful nervous I will get
there are your hands sweating yeah
you're gonna sweat that's good yeah
that's the kind of wire here if your
hands sweat then that's that's your yes
sign of like I should do that yeah
sometimes not always so you're you're
the next chapter as you start getting
involved in these adventure races you do
like the the rate Galatoire's right an
eco challenge and all these crazy races
that Mark Burnett kind of put on the put
on them on the road map that were on
television and all of that and that's
really what took you to Vietnam the
first time right yeah adventure racing
was
kind of my education in teamwork and
doing lots of different sports and like
you said there weren't very many women
involved and that was the time period
where I was running Rakesh in and
running a climbing gym in huh these
people came in who were kind of least
dorky they didn't fit in with climbing
vibe there in like tights and you know
tank top you know really tight clothing
and the climbers are all wearing baggy
stuff and people come in and like to the
rock gym and they're like we need to
learn how to rappel Michael like people
don't repel they climb like the
rappelling is just like the way down
it's like taking an escalator or
whatever and like yeah we need to learn
to rappel for Adventure Racing and I
didn't know what it was but does it
manage your oh the gym I'm like sure
I'll take your money you know we'll
teach you how to rappel and those were
all people who were getting involved
with adventure racing and so they had to
learn the Rope work and that's how I got
pulled into it because the team makeup
has to be co-ed so at the time it was
traditionally three guys one girl and so
I got roped in they're like oh you look
pretty strong you're a girl you want to
be on one of our team so my first
adventure race here was in Malibu oh wow
and it was a qualifier for the
Australian eco challenge and it was 24
hour race and I was just like I can't
sit on the couch for 24 hours let alone
do an activity and I wasn't a cyclist I
did sort of two out of the five sports
and how old were you then Oh probably
early thirties and I was rock climber
and a paddler and I had run in high
school in college so that was good
enough and they threw me on a bike that
was too small and into the you know into
the hills in Malibu but we end up
winning the whole race uh-huh like uh
you know this is terrible we've just won
a trip to go do this for seven do it
again yeah for longer and I actually was
like well that's great we won there's no
way I'm going and doing this for ten
days but we went I figured well it's a
free trip to Australia I'll go so that
was kind of were you still living in
your car no I was managing the rock gym
and living here and and the adventure
racing is really what moved me into my
car because I kept getting invited on
these cool trips to go travel the world
and fill up passports and only
way I could financially make it work as
if I didn't have rent and so I quit my
dream job moved into the Bronco that I
had at the time and headed to Moab and
just headed out into the desert and
became a dirt bag right and so you did
these adventure races and like kicked
ass at them for like a number of years
right ten years are socially a
professional athlete professional
athlete that didn't make any money in
your car yeah yeah no health insurance
you know eating ramen ramen noodles and
two non you know mooching off friends
and staying on couches and but it was it
was my travel experience it was you know
my PhD and travel and seeing the world
and and and really team dynamics of what
people are like when they're cold and
hungry and lost and yeah and you were in
Vietnam for one of those right yeah
Vietnam was pretty powerful 3i yeah I
think that was 2003 and that was my
first really big jungle race and it was
really the first time that I started
thinking about the soldiers of Vietnam
because we were getting trench foot and
we would at night we'd take all of our
clothes off because we had heat rash
yeah and just hiked with our clothes off
because it was physically pretty
miserable nothing in comparison to
obviously foot soldiers and people being
on the ground and and living in that
atmosphere got a taste of the day might
have been like without getting you know
ammunition right without being shot at
or anything but a taste of the the
brutality of that landscape and how hard
it is to travel through that landscape
and also seeing the remnants of tunnels
and you know bomb craters and seeing the
history of what happened and that was
the first time that I you know all
growing up I never asked my mom
questions about my dad there were always
people who'd come up and oh I feel so
sorry for you grew up without a dad but
it's hard to mourn something that you
don't know and I don't have any memories
of him and so as a kid I was just sort
of like I didn't know how to feel sad
about I didn't really know what I was
missing basically and
trip to Vietnam was the first time when
my mom came with me so after the race we
took a little tour and went around and
that's the first time I really asked her
or talked to her about him in my whole
life
Wow and I think it was therapeutic for
her to finally be like okay we're gonna
talk about this and stand on China Beach
and stand in the places that he had
written letters home from and she saved
all those letters I never looked at him
I never asked about it so it was the
beginning of an opening for us that
would take still another 10 12 years to
continue to open that wound but it was a
cure it start it's piqued my curiosity
of what is the Ho Chi Minh Trail and and
what's it like and what's Vietnam like
and what did dad really go through right
and there was a lot of mystery around
his crash right like they hadn't you
didn't know whether he survived the
crash or there was no confirmation of
his remains or anything like that for a
number of years yeah they didn't find
any of his remains until 2007 and and
unfortunately that's pretty common that
the planes go down there are tons of you
know people still missing who have not
yet been identified his copilot was
never identified even though they found
the crash site they didn't find any
remains to be confirmed uh-huh so was
there a sense that he could have been a
prisoner of war and you just didn't know
yeah absolutely I had I I will say you
know I did have nightmares as a kid I
dream about my dad I dream about meeting
him in a coffee shop telling him about
my life and that was a reoccurring dream
that I had for a long time that that I
would meet him and you know there were
thoughts of duty of a family was he
living in Vietnam did he did he leave us
or did he abandon us and start over I
mean we've all seen those movies and
you've seen the films and and it does
happen and so there was as a kid of you
know what did really happen and he know
it comes and goes it wasn't a daily part
of my existence but it's obviously
that's infiltrating my dreams there's
something deep in my soul that had
questions to be answered you know in
2007 they finally found two teeth at the
crash site it was the second or third
excavation of
that site and ironically my sister is a
dentist and in the Air Force and she was
able through clearance to actually go
and and look and identify the teeth and
and and bring the background
yeah and confirmed so it was a really
interesting tie to her chosen profession
and career has there never been a
general who's also a dentist
well she entered through the dentist
there hasn't been there are many
generals who come in to the Air Force
through the medical and so yeah her path
has been a little different but yeah she
came in through the medical side but she
doesn't
unfortunately the higher you get in the
ranks the less you actually do your
practice right yeah if you're a general
you're not why he's filling cavities
she's not doing that in heart no she's
making decisions for ya the whole
military medical system now at this
point so the adventure racing thing kind
of runs its course and the rug gets
pulled out from underneath you because
those TV shows all kind of go away right
they do go away although he's bringing
them back yeah Mark Burnett apparently
is bringing back eco-challenge ah about
the interesting yeah you want to race on
a team I don't know oh man you're crying
me today
maybe we'll see start with a gentle
mountain bike we all heard it yeah but
that kind of created a little bit of a
void for you right like a oh man what am
I gonna do now
like a little bit of a dismantling like
I had this good thing going what's the
next chapter gonna look like for me now
that I can't continue to you know make
my way yeah I was playing I was playing
along dune adventure racing traveling
the world and came to a screeching halt
with the death of a friend and with
adventure racing you know losing
sponsorship and not just kind of dying
out and yeah there was a period of again
a dark sort of time of what am i doing
with my life
you know what is this college degree or
what am I really gonna do and and it's
really interesting but that's where I
found mountain biking and that has been
and really I just went the reason I win
on this I went to a 24-hour race
a bunch of girlfriends as a therapy and
it kind of goes back to the
cross-country running days you know when
when I'm in my deepest darkest holes
it's it's usually physical activity and
a few a very small group of friends that
people that pull me out of it if I'm
left to my own devices I don't do well
but it takes me a while to reach out so
I reached out to some girlfriends and
let's go do this mountain bike thing in
Moab I just heard of it 24 hours in my
lab and you know it's October so it's
not a great time to be in the mountains
because it's just muddy and not ski
season yet and so we went to Moab and
slipped out in the desert and rode
around in circles for 24 hours and to me
it had all the ingredients that I've
been missing which was community and
working hard and challenging myself and
we did really well and I ended up I was
running most of the technical sections
was a lousy mountain biker so I just
keyed off and run and then ride super
fast on the flat sections just try to
make up for lost time and Holy's people
saw me just jumping off my bike
shouldering it running down the
technical stuff don't be back on but it
was it was therapeutic and I ended up
having the fastest laps of all the women
in the race and you know we won the sort
of intermediate and or whatever division
I'm lucky being your weakest discipline
yeah terrible hair this becomes your
greatest strength it's kind of weird
ya know it has been and you know at 38
basically decided okay well I'll lose
mountain bike thing for a little while
and it was really the endurance that I
was good at the 24 hours was kind of
like that's no big deal you know Eco
challenges were seven days so 24 hours
was one night you be in your bed the
next night you know there's you don't
really get into sleep deprivation in 24
hours so it was fine so it was good at
that part of it and that was but I just
wasn't any good at writing about yeah
well because you essentially win every
mountain bike race that you enter after
this you end up dominating Leadville
winning it many times in the long run
it's not the short ones you know not the
you know super technical undersell
yourself probably loved thank you but I
will say I'm
and I found that the longer it is and
this is you know a different it's kind
of a mountaineering mindset you know or
I feel like Mountaineers and ultra
endurance athletes are very similar and
that it's not necessarily how how really
technically skilled you are I mean of
course you have to be at a certain level
but it's it's more can you keep going
this sort of slow burn consistent
mindset to do really long things like
that mm-hmm yeah it's not about how fast
you're going it's just you're you're
persistent forward motion and not
slowing down right so and taking care of
yourself and having the mental the
mental sort of agility or whether it's
it's this sort of detached focus it's
hard for me to explain of what I think
about when I'm in really long events and
I heard you talking about how you listen
to podcasts and music sometimes and I'll
go back and forth between that stuff but
there is a you have to take yourself out
of the moment of the pain at the moment
but also be focused and in the moment
and I'm not
I need a term for that but it's a very
interesting it says form of meditation
yeah I mean focus but losing track of
time yeah your relationship with time
becomes very malleable like it it's not
linear and when you can get in that
state where you're in that aerobic zone
where your hearts beating and your lungs
are heating but not too hard there's
this weird thing that happens where it's
not that time speeds up it just become
your perception of time is altered and
so hours can go by but it doesn't feel
like it's like if you're driving your
car across country by yourself like the
first day is the hardest day because you
have ants in your pants like not used to
sitting down but then like day
two-and-a-half like you'll be driving
for hours and hours and it's like a
blink of an eye and you don't even
realize what you've just driven through
it's like this weird flow state that you
get into I had a kind of a revelation
after I came back from Ho Chi Minh Trail
and I think I mentioned I was I was in
kind of a dark place and that was the
first time I started dabbling with
still a meditation sitting still and
trying to meditate you know it was
really great for me to experience that
and to have the revelation that I've
been meditating all along but in
movement and not sitting still and it
was the same exact feeling like you said
of of time takes it on a different
meaning and for me to be able to find
that while I'm not moving was pretty
eye-opening for me during my activities
to go oh yeah I've been doing this so
long I had no idea you know why I've
been doing that and that was a big like
I said at the beginning sitting down and
looking inside instead of being in
constant notion but it was reassuring to
know that the ultra-endurance stuff has
been fueling me in that way as a soul
searching and as a therapy of sorts yeah
I think it works that way for a lot of
people but I think it is you know if you
it's important to point out that there
are like I know people that are part of
the community that I think are deal with
their pain or their trauma by training
and racing a little bit too much and
they're they're kind of running away
from what they really need to look at
and as long as they keep moving they
never have to look at that thing and
work through it because stopping will
force them to do that that's too painful
so it's easier to just keep moving
forward and then there's the healthier
relationship with it which is to
leverage it and use it as a means of
therapy to work through those things
those things that we all have you're
exactly right and that revelation didn't
come to me until after the Ho Chi Minh
Trail of stopping for a minute and
stopping the racing and sitting still
and then realizing I could take my sport
you know the next evolution of my sport
might still involve racing but it was
going to be with a very different
mindset of not necessarily chasing a
podium and if a podium comes along the
way great but that wasn't the initial
goal anymore it
it's deeper and bigger than that and and
it it has taken me until now to figure
that out and and I did wrought trailers
one of the first big expeditions I've
done since the Ho Chi Minh Trail where
it was a personal really big personal
challenge it's the first one since since
then so it's taken four years since I
went and did the Ho Chi Minh Trail - I
think come around - how can I feed my
competitive spirit but also feed my soul
and I did ride is the first one of those
where I am taking what I knew be fleet I
was before to the human that I am now
well that's a mature dart and it's a
it's a roller coaster ride
absolutely so let's get into it so in
your father's remains are discovered and
and you know I gather from your story
that this was kind of like okay now I
need to go and like really explore this
relationship with my father I've been to
Vietnam before I have a sense of it but
now with knowing where he crashed like I
want to go connect with that it was not
as articulated that clearly there was a
curiosity about him my sister obviously
you know when the remains were found
there was a whole military you know
arlington ceremony and frankly i didn't
want to go I didn't want to celebrate
the war and this is where it's been hard
on my family you know I didn't you know
they do a 21-gun salute right and did
you not go then I went for my family and
for my sister and mom and I felt it felt
so ironic to me that we're shooting guns
to celebrate the very tool that killed
him I really struggled with that and if
you've been to Arlington looking across
all those white headstones and it's not
a peaceful place for me to hang out I
could rough there
yeah and that the most impactful part of
that day was not the ceremony itself and
I mean I'm glad the government and we
celebrate when people come home and
their remains are found we have to and
we have to keep looking but for me the
most impactful part of the day was
behind the scenes off on the side away
from the ceremony were all these Vietnam
vets with Harley's and their jackets on
and patches from the war and I was sort
of drawn to that group of people more
than the people in uniform yeah this
kind of yeah the outliers and the people
who kind of didn't quite fit in and
that's a little bit how I felt that day
did some of his his friends from that
time show up yeah yeah the Joe Leone and
some other people you know came up and
said I knew your dad and you know we're
glad he's home and you know showed us
pictures and you looked just like him
and you know that was I was a I think I
was in shock but that really was the
beginning of I can look back now
eyesight is 20/20 and go yeah I have
been on this path to go to those map
coordinates for a long time and meeting
those people that was impactful for me I
felt like that was more of a connection
to him than then I'd ever felt because I
knew him and they were there and they
experienced the same thing and my
adventure racing career and you know
sponsorship and all that has been this
really interesting circuitous journey
that I do believe was leading there all
the time and you know I needed skills
and Matt Backus and all this expertise
done all the things they had done in
order to be prepared to handle that it's
true
I couldn't have gone it's like my 30s or
20s very easy looking back how like
every Domino lined up perfectly to put
you in a position to be able to embark
upon that adventure
I'm glad you notice that because I
notice it and it seems clear as day like
of course right you know but while I'm
in it leaving out on my car and doing
all these things and then changing a
mountain biking and none of that would
have seemed like it was lining up if you
had just been a mountain bike racer you
wouldn't you
I've had the skill set to be able to do
adventure racing and the rock client
like all of that whitewater you know all
of it so when does it crystallize as
okay the Ho Chi Minh Trail that's what
I'm gonna do it crystallized and I I
mean I have to thank redbull for this
they've been a partner for almost 20
years with me and every year and stead
of you know telling me what I have to do
they ask me well what do you want to do
and they've pushed me to think of new
and creative ideas so I just started
thinking about what are the cool what
cool places could I go ride my bike that
I could ride a long way and you know a
lightbulb finally went off that was like
the Ho Chi Minh Trail this iconic Trail
I don't think anyone's done it and oh by
the way that's where my dad is and you
know I could the sort of two parts of my
world could come together for the first
time in my life of my personal life and
and my career but really it started as a
bike adventure and maybe I could go do
that and I pitched the idea for two or
three years it didn't didn't stick to
Red Bull and got denied and I'm I'm kind
of glad that it did because I wasn't
ready yet I was still racing Leadville
and still in you know chasing podiums
and doing all that and they weren't
ready as a company to tell this kind of
a story and it's not your typical Red
Bull film and basically I went to them
because I knew I needed help the maps
alone the logistics just saw daunting
and so yeah the magnitude of trying to
pull this thing off his massive so I
didn't go to say let's make a movie I
went and said will you help me with the
logistics of this we helped me try to do
this expedition fully thinking I was
just gonna do it by myself maybe with my
husband or a friend who's a cyclist and
and just go do it and have a personal
journey but it grew into a big story in
a documentary film and really grateful
that it did because it's you know I'm
not wanting to tell my own story really
even though we're here talking about it
well it seems like it happened very
organically like it it wasn't like we're
gonna make a movie like oh maybe we'll
shoot something just the story kind of
got bigger and bigger
bigger and you know you had Red Bull
there to document everything and then
the realization that like hey this is
this is there's a bigger story to be
told here than just some adventure clips
and a short little mini thing yeah the
the cycling almost became it was the
vehicle and it was my tool to explore
but you know the bike really wasn't the
main part of it it was the way I got
there it's my process to ride twelve
hundred miles like people asked why
didn't you just go to that map court you
had them out quarters why did you just
go there which I could have but for me I
needed to do it in my way which was
physically stripping away getting tired
traveling a long way immersing in the
culture you know riding with a
Vietnamese partner and being part of it
and but really stripping away the
emotional layers and the the sort of
force field that we put up around
ourselves I needed to do that to be
ready to you know I'm not a really open
person the vulnerability was totally new
for me especially being documented and
the bike was like okay at least I know I
can put my head down and ride for ten
hours a day and and knowing now that I
needed that as a therapy and a
processing and to take my time getting
to the mountain coordinates to take a
month I didn't know that much about the
Ho Chi Minh Trail I mean I thought I
need a road you know you're going it's
1,200 miles go through you know
beginning in North Vietnam with light
goes through Laos Cambodia and was there
traditionally to Shepherd weapons
artillery and supplies from the north
down to the south to the Vietcong right
but I had no sense of just how difficult
and technical and I mean it's really
barely a trail at all it's yeah and some
places it's not a trail there's not a
sign that's like this way the Ho Chi
Minh Trail you know it's not so we put
together a historically accurate route
and it's really there's a spider web of
of trails and when you know the US would
bomb the trail they'd rebuild it again
and so there are places that are paved
there's places that are under reservoirs
or places that are you know in the
jungle or using machetes there's places
with original cobblestones still hand
laid that are still there and footpaths
that the villagers still use I mean Laos
is very undeveloped and a lot of those
paths and trails are still just used for
daily life yeah moving around I mean
given the difficulty of you traversing
it by mountain bike imagine you know all
these people like carrying you know
giant loads for that entire distance
like on the trail was I mean people died
all the time along the trail you leave
on that journey to move rice and
ammunition down the trail and not come
back yeah the striking thing in the film
is just how obliterated you know like
there's just the the landscape is just
lined with exploded artillery craters
the entire way yeah it is right I didn't
know that either
that was that was probably my biggest
surprise along the trail was one how
kind the people are and how they could
welcome the daughter of someone who was
bombing their families how they could
welcome me in and help me
and the second big surprise was the
amount of devastation that is still
there every day and the unexploded
ordnance every day that people are still
living with people who were never
weren't even born during the war there's
kids that have known nothing else than
having unexploded ordnance in their
village that's a huge part of the movie
that is what it's called uxl unexploded
ordnance yeah I didn't know that term
either yeah it's just everywhere and
that's become a big part like that's a
you know kind of a tangential outgrowth
it goes back to the service thing a way
for you to be able to be involved in you
know support these people that are you
know basically you know combing the
entire terrain to try to unearth these
things and explode them yeah mines
advisory group is the organization I
work with but
that is I mean not just clearing in Laos
or clearing in all the war-torn
countries and sort of everywhere we go
we leave a wake of explosives long after
the war is gone and done and we leave
that you know as our parting gift to the
the locals that live there and
thankfully there's organizations that
that work and go clean up that mess and
and I couldn't really have to do go over
it with a fine-toothed common and they
cover it again right just to make sure
yeah the process is very labor intensive
extremely labor intensive that is metal
detectors and then fine-tuning the metal
detector and then hand digging out that
unexploded ordnance and in a jungle
place like Laos you know it's harder to
clear in a desert environment they can
send instead of it happy to be human
clearance you know they can send
machinery and you know other ways but
not in the jungle terrain you can't do
that in Laos and so it is by hand and
the that allowed people it's actually a
really good job in Laos to work for
mines advisory group and to have a
steady paycheck to help clean up your
country yeah there are those scenes of
you with that organization in that group
and you you explode you know ordnance
it's crazy it the sound of that I mean
it makes me cry every time because you
feel it reverberate in your chest and
your body and you imagine we don't hear
that as Americans you know we don't hear
or feel that noise
and when you hear it and it shakes the
trees and it shakes your chest it's hard
for me not to feel guilty and imagine
living there and hearing that every day
raining you know you know 24 hours a day
hearing that noise and the fear and I
mean you've you've talked to people come
back you know for more with PTSD and the
sound of the bombs is something I don't
think anyone will forever forget and I
had never heard it before I went to help
you know with the clearance and I I feel
like that's part of if if we go to a
place we hear a sound we smell a smell
there's you know you see all our senses
are involved when you actually immerse
yourself in an experience like that and
it goes a lot deeper when you smell in
here and see and taste something versus
seeing it in a movie yeah I mean I've
never experienced that my whole
relationship with that is is on a movie
screen yeah we're on a television it's
it's powerful and it it is why after
leaving there it was so clear to me that
this ride was no longer about me and my
journey and it was so clear that you
know my dad brought me there to father
me and teach me and say hey well you
take what you have with your cycling in
your career and and help clean up this
mess yeah I mean I feel to the core of
my soul that I was meant to be there and
he brought me there too to father me and
teach me and you know tell me what the
next steps were with my bike you know
still with my bikes still adventuring
but to to have a different a different
purpose on it that's a lot bigger than
me
that's that's it's such a beautiful
sentiment and and truth I feel like it's
true I don't know it's it can't not be
true there are too many things that you
could can't chalk up to coincidence and
you know meeting people that served with
my dad and learning map and compass and
just all of it that's lined up it can't
be coincidence I really do believe I was
brought there yeah so how does that kind
of inform your your on this interior
journey now right like you know how do
you think of yourself as a as a
spiritual being like what is your
spiritual perspective on this I mean it
just seems like it couldn't be any other
way what's been really apparent to me is
the connectivity of humans and how these
threads of people you've never met in
your whole life that but you still are
connected and I don't know the terms to
explain it you know but that the the
village man that I met who is the son
the father who buried my father and you
know meeting him face to face and we'd
met a lot of Lao villagers along the way
and I didn't know that we were pulling
up to his house you know I knew her near
the place and this village chief was
gonna take me there and I locked eyes
with this guy you know the million not a
hundred law villager who we'd met along
the way I locked eyes with this person
and there was something about him I
couldn't stop staring at him and he
smiled at me and I smiled at him and
then found out later that his dad buried
my dad and and he was gonna take me
there and he even his mother was
pregnant at the time of the crash and so
his dad had told him this whole story
growing up and the village shaman had
said to the mom you know when one soul
dies another is born and you know this
soldier is basically in your belly in
you this is part of you and so mr. air
when he's telling me this through a
translator he reaches down and shows me
and he has it's kind of a funny story he
has six toes and he pointed to his six
toe and said see this is proof that we
we're brother and sister you know we're
a part of each other and I've never met
this man he lives in a hut in the middle
of the jungle and yet we're connected
and when I went back the time again a
year later you know I've taken trips
back there now three times and I asked
him you know were you surprised to see
me and he's like no and then the last
time I went and I you know I kind of
asked again I said did you know we were
coming back and he said yeah I had a
dream I saw you in a dream a month ago I
knew you're coming Wow and I believe him
these things like the connectivity of
humans is just fascinating to me and
people that have served with my dad
we've become good friends my sister and
I become closer because of it all and
there is there is a reason behind it all
and and so yeah what are you using call
it spirituality or connect connectivity
but it's to me reinforces how important
it is that we find community in our
lives whether it's through your running
club or your family or through a charity
or whatever it is that humans have to
make connections that's really amazing
it is it's it's like it doesn't need a
label you know just the telling of the
story is enough well not so much there's
so much on wonder and beauty in that
story and I think if you really take it
to heart and listen there's so much that
we can learn about purpose and finding
meaning in our lives like you know big
thing with you is learning to trust your
instincts and follow your guts and like
chase that curiosity and it's found its
way you know in all of these athletic
pursuits that you've done but you know
honing that brought you to that place
and to those people that came from
within you you didn't need to go back
and retrace these steps and try to find
your father you didn't even remember him
but there was a calling you know deep
within you to do that and you know what
blossomed from that are these amazing
relationships and that serendipity is
just unbelievable unbelievable you made
a really good point of listening and I
don't think I was listening for a long
time and what I've learned yeah is is to
listen to my gut I mean I listen to my
gut living on my car I want to go rock
climbing and I I have listened but I
feel like I'm truly listening more now
and what's the difference between then
and now the biggest difference is that
I'm not just listening to me I want to
go rock climbing I want to do this do
that I'm it's like a horse with blinders
on the blinders are spread out a little
bit past my eyes then then just straight
forward and a big part of the Ho Chi
Minh Trail riding with my Vietnamese
teammate who was slower than I was doing
a film which is slower you know I could
have done the whole thing a lot faster
Rebecca style by myself and there was a
part of me that was really frustrated
along this journey by having to slow
down and but that is truly what was the
one of the biggest frustrations for me
truly became the biggest gift because
slowing down made me sit by the side of
the trail and look at the butterflies or
journal or voice record along the trail
I was waiting for the film crew or human
and it was the slowing down that allowed
me to take the blinders off and listen
not just to my heartbeat and this and
what's going on with me but to listen to
what's going on and see what's going on
around me so that's the biggest
difference in you know me versus looking
outside and what's bigger a bigger
sphere human has her own amazing story
she's awesome and she that she's also
grown from this trip and now has a cafe
in in Hanoi and has rediscovered cycling
and has cycling groups now and I think
it was a real it was a really healing
process for her as well what is the you
know if I'd like you to kind of describe
the experience the life experience of
some of these villagers that you
connected with along the way there was a
woman who like lived in she was a girl
and was in like basically lived in a
cave for six years to come out and find
her village gone and you know what is it
that you kind of gleaned or learned from
spending time with these people along
the way it's it's really the fact that
they live in the moment and I touched on
this a little bit there was no animosity
towards us I fully expected to go in
there as an American looking for a US
soldier to you know imagine if someone
came to your house knocked on your door
and said can I dig around in your
backyard
my dad was bombing here you know and
want to go look for him would you
would you say come on in you know and oh
by the way you know I killed you know
your family and I was part of that would
you open your door and welcome them in
or would there be this part of you
that's like wait you're coming from the
Vietnam War and there was never a moment
of blame or looking back and he went
even says it said it to me she said the
past has passed and
we can only control now in the future
and I really felt like the villagers
there you know they have a different
life perspective they're just trying to
survive so what tomorrow is or what
yesterday was is not what they're
thinking about they're thinking about
right now and spending time with their
family have enough food and farming
their land and that living in the moment
and not holding on to blame or grudge or
what happened is pretty powerful I don't
I'm not particularly good at that I
don't think Americans are particularly
good at letting go of that and yeah the
woman that I met a visitor every time I
go back and she speaks no English ice on
the cake
no Lao yeah she lived in that was her
life she lived in a cave all of her
children are born in the cave and they
were there and they have grandchildren
now and she's sitting happily in huts
around surrounded by bomb craters but
she's she's home and that is her home
and it's sort of a just it may seem
simplistic you know I took one of my
mountain bike friends that I took on the
first MTB loud trip you know she met the
woman with me and this is a friend who
lives in Idaho with me and has two kids
and a zappiti and you know and she's and
I said the woman you know I see her
every year and she's wearing the same
clothes and she's sitting in the same
place in her hut uh-huh making rice and
Caroline said to me God she must be so
bored well it's easy for us to have a
lot of judgment about that well I'm not
so I said I said she might be happier
than we are yeah she might be she seems
perfectly content and it's that
perspective it's why I keep going back
to refresh myself of the simplicity of
the perspective but also what I'm
working for to help them live a peaceful
safe life there's no reason that they
should have to worry about an exploded
ordnance well Americans are weird
because we live these fast-paced hairy
you know complicated modern lives and we
all know or we've had direct experience
with other cultures that have
things down and are more integrated with
their community and live you know quote
unquote what we would call simplistic
lives but they're undeniably happier and
they seem to be you know have joy and
love in their lives and the important
you know boxes seem to be checked but
their lifestyles so foreign to us that
we have trouble relating and as much as
we kind of intellectually understand
like wow they're happier like I could
use more of that in my life we kind of
return home and then just go about doing
whatever it is we were doing and like I
question whether we really learn
anything from this well how do you bring
that back home and it's one write that
into your life or layers of that into
your life
I've not been totally successful yeah
that's why I need to keep going back and
learning the lesson and it's why I keep
writing well I'll never stop going on
adventures because apparently I need to
keep learning lessons over and over
again yeah well one of the things that
you're involved in that I think is
really cool is this organization or what
is it article 22 that makes beautiful
jewelry out of the scrap metal from the
ordinance yeah you actually brought like
probably some bracelets yeah take this
out they're really cool also tell me
about this yeah I can't when I came back
feeling this strong sense of purpose
that I need to do something about the
unexploded ordnance and the bombs and
you know I'm looking around online and
they came across article 22 out of New
York and this woman Elizabeth who she
had a similar experience tied it to not
similar but she had travelled in Laos
and she was looking for textiles and she
came across we've got some different
sizes or gay she came across this little
village Navia village in northern Laos
in the plain of jars area where the
secret war went on and where the US CIA
base was where we weren't supposed to be
and this this small village one village
and all of Laos they were making spoons
out of the Unabomber's though aluminum
from the bomb casings and airplane parts
and they were they had homemade kilns
melting down making spoons and
she went to this village and was just
like if they can make spoons out of them
you know they taken they'd made
something useful and she's like well
what what else could they make and so
she started this company article 22 that
that makes bracelets earrings jewelry
from the bombs from the unexploded
ordnance and they employ the lab
villagers she runs a business you know
basically through facebook messenger
with this one village and there they're
all sold here in the US and across the
United States and so I partnered with
her I asked her the the words on there
be good
my dad he signed all his letters home
from the Vietnam War with the words be
good every single one said be good Steve
and so I asked her you know and really
that's the purpose I took from my trip
from the Ho Chi Minh Trail is be good
and interpret that however you want for
me you know there is from a bomb that
was dropped from yeah this guy yeah and
hopefully eventually this company will
close and you know they won't have any
more material to work with eventually
because it'll be gone and I'll be used
but but yeah it's taking something
devastating and horrible and making it
into a beautiful reminder and the
bracelets really mind me remind me of
the MIAA bracelets do you know what
those were no so missing an action is
what am ia is and and their I think it
was a US Postal Service they did a big
campaign during the Vietnam War with
bracelets of you know that you could
wear an aluminum bracelet with engraved
with someone's name who was missing and
their their rank and their and their the
date they went missing and people would
you know wear these bracelets for
strangers I've had people reach out and
be like I wore your dad's bracelet until
the day he was found and it was a really
amazing program and these new sort of
happier aluminum bracelets they kind of
remind me of that is is it's kind of
taking that a memento with legacy of
that yeah and to look down and and look
at something and have her remembrance
it's kind of like we talked about how do
you bring back those memories and what
you learned somewhere
and and have it in your daily life as a
reminder and to me the bracelets are you
look down at jingles you yeah you think
about what is this made of and and who
made it and and can we clean up all of
it so that it's gone and a portion of
the proceeds goes to that organization
that's clearing yeah
every bracelet clears 12.5 square meters
of land in Laos in my dad's name through
my foundation I now of a be good
foundation just became official oh wow
501c3 so it's been a process but I'm
taking my bike in this film and these
bracelets um as a way to to use my bike
to make a difference and that can
involve adventures or bracelets or movie
tours but it's it's actually super
exciting that my business you know I
sort of give air quotes when I say but
my business has evolved into still
feeding my soul with adventuring and
cycling but now this this whole bigger
part of it which is to help people heal
by riding a bicycle it's crazy like what
your life has become like living in a
Bronco - because you do so many things
like you're not just an athlete you're a
race director and you've got this
nonprofit and you're doing all these
things to empower women and you've got
you know the brace it's like it's it's
like how do you even have the time to
Train I don't really it really
complicated it does get complicated but
I mean I have to do these things it's I
was 8 when I came back from blood road I
had a down period and I really wrote
down would always stand for like how am
I gonna make choices I don't know where
I'm going but how do I do what are my
core values not and I wrote him down I
went through that exercise and and I
have a bit of a road map thanks to dad I
don't know so what are those core values
what does that look like it's a set of
equations and I can look back to the
Bronco days and all that and they all
kind of fall in line but the the later
ones have evolved a little bit and touch
on not having enough time for training
but it all starts to me with risk equals
reward that's the first one passion
equals payoff
give equals get which is part of all
this foundation sharing and then the
final one that you just touched on that
less equals more and that you know if I
fill my life up too much you know kind
of back to that simplicity is it better
to do more and that's I think probably
where you live and I live now in it
spaces in our life of what do we say no
to inundated with requests or
invitations to do lots of cool stuff I
am and again going back to Iditarod
that's that's why I need to just go ride
alone for long distances mmm you know
because that is the core of who I am
that's that kid in Downers Grove
Illinois who wanted to go camp in the
backyard is I can't lose sight of that
through everything else and now this
movie this movie that you made won an
Emmy it did win and I'm crazy it that
movie tour and I you know Jimmy and chai
and all those guys are going through
that right now it's it's a hard road to
it's harder to share your story than not
share your story but the gift of that
film and blood road and and the hard
work and no training of the of sharing
the film it touched so many veterans and
families and kids and people write me
still every week of like thank you I saw
this you know my dad was in the Korean
War or my family did this or and it's
been a really it just shows me again how
important it is that it's not just about
me it's it's not my film anymore it's so
it's actually a way to help people and
to touch people and to to heal from the
atrocities of war is it still are you
still touring with it I'm using it now
as a fundraising tool it's not an
official tour anymore but I'm using it
as a tool for my foundation so people
can request to host a screening they can
you know request to have me and so it's
a great tool to go and give a speech to
a film and and it's a it's an evergreen
story
unfortunately the bombs aren't cleared
up yet
they have a long way to go they do and
so so yeah it's um it's a tool that I
have to do my job which is amazing right
so let's talk about your 50 now I am
right yeah I can say it now yeah I know
you're smiling well Aaron 49 I was all
like haha what am I gonna do
when I turn 50 what I'm gonna say when I
turned 50 and you know it's like I'm 50
I'm killing it you're crushing it so I
guess my question is likes are you how
do you think about aging and how has
your training and your racing evolved
with time and age like in a very like
physical way like like you have to do
things differently are you still feeling
the way that you did a 40 like how is it
different how do you adapt and evolve
the biggest thing I noticed is I do all
the things that we all should do anyway
I have to stretch more I have to sleep
more I have to drink more water I can't
be lazy about the whole picture anymore
uh-huh all those things as we know when
we're 20 30 40 you know you're supposed
to do that stuff you don't right there's
no there's less there you have to be
sort of more complete in the preparation
which is fine it just it requires more
commitment more time
you know it's you've got it a lot more
time to go stretch you gotta take longer
to warm up you know this was stretching
like do like foam rolling and what other
kinds of like foam rollers a big part of
it um lots of little balls and toys and
rubber bands and things I have some
great body workers at home that I see a
little more regularly than than I would
have when I was living out of my Bronco
I don't really see you a body worker
foam rollers weren't around at that time
[Laughter]
yeah and and I six it up a little bit
more - I do I do a lot of trail running
with my dogs I swim a little bit because
I feel like it's really good for you I
you know do yoga just becoming a little
bit more well-rounded the biggest
challenge I'm finding and you you
already talked about it is as I get
older and I get busier and there's more
demands on my
time it's harder to carve out and really
be diligent about protecting my training
time and probably that is my biggest
challenge right now is not that I need
to stretch more drink more water is I
need actually really dedicate time to
myself and and that's part of my job and
nobody can touch that so I I could learn
maybe from you on being diligent about I
don't know my boundary is a little too
permeable you know I I should I think I
can learn from you about you know being
more protective of that time will and
honestly this it's hard in a daily
routine but this is why I will continue
to sign up for events because when I'm
in Alaska nobody can touch me
when I'm out on the trail and I really
am in an event and I say I'm gonna be
off the grid for two weeks then truly
nobody can get to me and that really is
precious time for me so so now I'm in in
sort of the the mode of planning really
big adventures so at least you know a
few times a year or once a month I'm
going in doing a big ride and scary
enough to keep you honest scary enough
to keep me honest and then also really
be off the grid and you know where I
live there isn't cell phone coverage
when I'm mountain bike riding and I
think those are those are my ways of
protecting the boundaries yeah what does
the training look like like how
structured are you with it do you work
with a coach coach Dean are you
listening I guess you do work I do work
with a coach Dean College he's he's
awesome he's he's uh I've worked with
him for years and I was really about to
you know I need to call him today and be
like hey I need more structure I need
you to kick my butt a little bit because
he was patient with me as I it's really
after you know my trainings been a lot
less structured since I came back from
blood road and I've done a bunch of
stuff and I've dabbled but it's time now
I've had the evolution and the
processing that now I do want to get
back to some more serious training so
typically when I'm on track it will you
know the the basic core of it is is a
couple really long things a week and
then a few days of intervals a week I
mean it's it's really that basic you
know short or long short and hard or
long and
and and slow and everything else and so
this helps you kind of conceptualize
that and then it says okay here's is it
like a here today you do this to Mario
or is it just like here's the kind of
core work workouts that you got to get
in and you figure out how it works with
your schedule he'll put it on a calendar
and ideally that accountability is
really important for me it's just like
somebody saying you need to show up and
do this interview with patrol at this
time and it's like okay I'll be there
right and so in a best-case scenario
he'll put it all in a calendar and I see
it and I look and I plan my day and go
okay tomorrow's a big day I need to
schedule around that I haven't been that
great at it you know admittedly in the
in the last couple years so that's where
I am asking him to to get back and crack
the whip whip a little bit because I
think we all need we all need someone to
keep us accountable whether its family
or coach or boss or whatever and he let
me take a break for a while he was he's
very understanding of that but yes time
to get back to work I like how you
phrase that like he let you like he's
the boss and what's your relationship
with you know training devices like our
rate monitors and power meters and you
know the human optimization you know
whereby we're all using technology to
learn more about how our bodies function
like are you more of a naturalist or do
you rely on those things how you know
how does that work for ya I'm
middle-of-the-road
I think a power meter is the best tool
ever designed in the face of the earth
because it is very direct immediate
feedback that you are either progressing
or you're strong today or you're not and
it doesn't lie whereas a heart rate
monitor can lie if you're sick or you're
tired or whatever that's less accurate
yeah those are listening that aren't
super gearheads a power meter measures
the amount of force that you're exerting
on the pedals basically yeah and if
you're pushing down you're pushing down
and if you're not you're not and to me I
use that in training a lot as a measure
and and for me it's a reinforcement of
you we all have days where you think I'm
kind of sucking today and then you look
at the numbers and say oh no really
it wasn't that bad or oh it's time to
take a rest and for me I like that
direct feedback however I will I will
say I never use it racing it's on it's
recording so that Dean can look at it
and we can look at the metrics but I
always race if I feel and perception as
if you're looking at those numbers it
will unduly influence like if you think
oh wow I'm above my threshold I better
dial it back even if you're feeling good
I think it holds people back yeah
and I also think it keeps them from
being really in tune with how they're
actually feeling in the moment and
reading your body instead of reading a
number on the screen and it also you
know if your eyes are down glued glued
to the Garmin you're not looking around
I think that that it's important the
tools are great but they work best when
you're using them to develop that
intuition like you're so experienced I'm
sure even though you're not looking at
the the data or the numbers he could
probably say with extreme precision oh
yeah I was these were the watts that I
was at today and it would match up
because you're so connected and well
that's what's cool is I was an athlete
long before those gadgets were available
and so I developed a sense of how I'm
feeling and intuitively how I'm feeling
and then when the gadgets came along it
was like oh yeah reinforcement like oh
okay you know so yeah I do know what 200
Watts feels like I do know what this
feels like but they're also they're a
great measure that because we are all
busier they're a great measure that you
know you want quality time versus
quantity and it's a measure of like I'm
getting the most out of this workout I
have an hour I'm gonna get it done and
I'm gonna do the work and then it's like
cool so as a training tool I think
they're amazing as a tool to know your
body or to make decisions in racing I
don't you know I'd rather use my brain
yeah I'm with you and now at 50 is there
a shift in like the the balance of how
your training goes like do you feel like
you need to do more strengthen interval
stuff like that that that is more
important or less important like how has
it altered to kind of you know
correspond with the aging process or do
you not think about that or that
that uh I think about it um I feel like
I have such a library of years of doing
endurance and long stuff that for me I
get the most benefit and pop from doing
intervals doing strength doing short
hard things because that's not my
natural state it's less fun but it's
over faster but yes if I do the hard
work in that way
mm-hm it pays off in it yeah you know so
I was so huge and for years and years
and years of having done that you can
tap into it I do I feel like I can tap
into that pretty easily I can't tap into
speed unless I'm unless I'm really
working on it but but one feeds the
other and part of the reason I I
suffered so badly in Alaska is I I went
into that race kind of unfit and I know
it sounds sort of weird but I knew I
could finish the distance the distance
wasn't intimidating to me but I would
have felt a lot better if I'd gone in
with with more intervals and ER my belt
and and you know the bike was 65 pounds
so you know just heaving it up and over
some of these hills and stuff was was
pretty intense so I could have used a
training camp I know I exactly exactly
and what is your relationship with
suffering you know when people say like
oh you know why are you you know keep
why do you keep going up back to the
pain cave like what is it what is it
that you're getting out of it what are
you learning about yourself what is your
relationship with suffering I feel like
the pain cave or suffering or I feel
like there is a ancient I mean this is
nothing new as where we're physical
deprivation or you know whether it's a
you know fasting or whether it's going
into a sweat lodge
you know affecting your physical body
for me is a way to to kind of reach
inside my soul and access the inner body
by sort of some may call it torture or
her suffering or going into the pain
cave physically that actually allows me
to access Who I am emotionally and it
sounds a little strange but but
I said there's examples through history
of people accessing their mind by you
know changing their body and we talked
about mind-body connection or you know
you know it's all one thing but often
people are busy they're thinking they're
on email they're doing this that their
brain is so hyperactive and their body
is is inactive so for me I have to flip
it around and make my body extremely
active in order to to quiet my mind and
to calm my mind and and really think
about it Who I am as a person so it is a
it's a therapy it's an aesthetic
practice like you're it's a stripping
away and I think in that there's you
find truth I mean you found it running
I've listened to a really great episode
you did about running as spirituality
and Oh with Sanjay for a while yeah yeah
and it was really amazing you know here
is a beautiful guy hearing the stories
of yeah people running or you know in
the the Tara Mara Indians you know and
just as a spiritual practice where
self-transcendence right so this is
nothing new I don't think to it go
because I want to feel pain mm-hmm I go
because I want to feel joy and
enlightenment and and learn about myself
let's talk about how you think about
yourself as this you know role model for
female empowerment
do you like how do you navigate that I
mean one thing I've said it many times
on the podcast but yeah we don't do a
very good job in our culture of
championing the many powerful women out
there that are doing amazing things we
tend to shine the spotlight on you know
female quote-unquote role models that
that are perhaps not you know the best
and I think there's a lot of women out
there yourself included who are doing
amazing things that I think you know
give me hope as a father of two
daughters but is that something that you
are like conscious of and I mean I know
that you're out there trying to foster
you know empowerment's in the athletic
community with women but like how do you
think about these issues I I think about
it the same way as my mom did I'm just
lead by example and no one sets out to
be you know when I grow up I want to be
an inspiration yeah nobody doesn't have
or well if you do there's something
wrong with you I mean that yeah I've
made my choices organically and this is
how it all happened and and I do feel
like the the you know I've had mentors
in my life and and perhaps I am one for
other people but it's really just by
leading by example and you probably know
this with your kids you can tell them
something
you know brush your teeth before dinner
or before bed but if you don't do it
yourself your words don't have a lot of
meaning to them as a teacher and so for
me I feel a responsibility to speak up
and to speak out because I I do see this
shift and this change with more women in
politics and government and you know in
sports and CEOs it there is a change
happening slowly but it's happening and
and I'm part of it and it's exciting and
more I feel a responsibility then you
know anything else but but it's fun it's
so great and rewarding to see my nieces
you know going to college and playing
music and art and getting into
government and that's part of that give
equals get it's super evil I get more
back from you know even hosting an event
where I see other people crossing the
finish line with their arms in the air
and they're smiling like I'm as happy
helping facilitate that then I am racing
myself yeah YouTube camps too right yeah
do you want to come to camp you're gonna
give me in your world some way you can I
[Laughter]
I do in the campsite yeah I'm doing a
more work at home in Idaho one because
as part of my balance of wanting to stay
home more I love where I live and I live
in a great place too right
bicycles so why not invite people to
come to me and so then I get to ride I
get to stay home and I get to share with
friends the beautiful place that I live
so the Academy and and Rebecca's Private
Idaho are all part of me combining what
I need but also with a way to give back
to somebody else
aha and what is the the message like
let's envision in your mind there's a
young woman listening to this who
perhaps is flirting with the idea of
getting active but is intimidated and
you know doesn't live in a place where
there's the kind of culture that you
have and catch them like how can you
inspire that person to you know engage
with their physical being a little bit
more I think women and girls especially
are intimidating and I certainly was to
get involved with mountain biking I was
super intimidated I didn't understand
the equipment tell you won the first
race you ever entered well I was running
you know um but you feel you feel like
you don't know enough and there's an
intimidation factor that I might not be
good people might make fun of me I'm not
wearing the right thing I don't know the
right gear and and really I think that's
why I do try to host women and girls
camps and things because I think of you
you've got to just invite somebody in to
start with and as soon as you feel
comfortable enough to step out on your
own then you know then the floodgates
are open and so for anyone male or
female I think finding a community that
is supportive and whether it's your bike
shop or whether it's your friends or
whether it's a high school sport you
know they have high school mountain
biking in they have in school now high
school cycling League but it's hard to
do alone
and I even find that now at 50 you know
and we were talking about this my if my
training is not consistent if I do it
alone and so I've got to find some
people and I got to get Dean you know to
whip crack the whip a little bit but
none of us can achieve any of it by
ourselves when you're at home are you
doing most of the training by yourself
or do you have group rides that you do
Oh combination yeah no just by sort of
timing to factor in my day and a bunch
of my
friends work you know regular jobs I'll
do and I'm not a morning person so I'd
do a lot of afternoon training and
sometimes that'll be alone but then I do
need to I do need to pepper it in with
some groups and I have a you know a
group of three or four good buddies that
it will go do anything with me at any
time I won my friend I called the wart
because she's like oh I'll always be
there with you so I can give her any
like I've got to go away Venus workout
you know will you go do it with me and
she will you know she doing that sounds
terrible okay I'll go yeah that's cool
you gotta have that person yeah and to
keep you honest right looking at
thinking about your core values that you
just shared a few minutes ago how does
that line up with how you think about
like what's next when you're pondering
what your next crazy like are you will
you share what you're thinking about
doing that yeah I will I know I mean
those core values and the lesson from
the Ho Chi Minh Trail my dad and be good
I mean it's it's basically a trail map
for me you know it's it's kind of a
little checklist of you know when I'm
making my choices do they do they meet
those criteria and what's next that I'm
super excited about and it and it is a
evolution from the Ho Chi Minh Trail is
to and through this foundation it's it's
to to kind of tackle more of the famous
trails in the world and tell the stories
of them and I think next on the list I
did her a trail fell into that I think
next would be Lewis and Clark trail and
Silk Road is on the list and the ideas
to get to ride through history to tell
the story to adventure experience the
people along the way and talk about
whatever the current social issues are
you know whether it's public lands
whether it's unexploded ordnance and so
there's a big part of me that wants to
use that model of the of the Ho Chi Minh
Trail and blood road
go explore some of the other famous
chances well that could be like a
Netflix series just bang these things
out I mean it could feed my soul and you
know for the next 50 years or maybe not
that looks 50 but that's what it
alright that'd be great and then could
come along I would love that that's my
kind of deal where would you want a
rival Silk Road would be unbelievable
yeah there's I've been sort of on the
internet looking at trails are so many
great store what are these other trails
I mean there is the Trail of Tears is a
you know American there they're all
migratory or war or you know exploratory
like Lewis and Clark and the Oliver's
story or a religious pilgrimage you know
there's there's so many great trails in
the world so that is kind of what I'm
trying to form as is the next next
projects for me very cool well uh
awesome to talk to you we're gonna get
you in a bike ride yeah for sure
on the dirt I know I wish I had more
time today to ride with you yeah busy
lives man well camp in Idaho rush
Academy starts in early June early June
yeah look at my calendar it's the best
month in Idaho as the wild flowers start
blooming yeah alright we'll talk okay
cool thank you you are an absolute
inspiration
it's incredible what you've done it's
super inspiring so thank you for sharing
with me thanks for talking about it and
get me back on with my coach Dean hello
appreciate ya Dean get me back to
joining this girl did your help it's
official now if people want to check out
blood road it's available on a multitude
of yeah rebel TV iTunes Amazon Prime and
then blood road film calm if somebody
wants to host a screening and be part of
the be good foundation or my website is
Rebecca rush just Hama has everything
there yeah and the book thank you for
bringing this I look forward to reading
this Russia glory this is awesome so
maybe you come back and after I read
this come back we can talk more okay
that sounds really good all right cool
thank you all right peace
plants mount bikes
[Laughter]
[Music]